so this is the the cocktail question
that I now ask people and I you know you
never you never know what kind of answer
you're gonna get or if you're even gonna
get an answer but just to think about
are we better off without all social
media you get you get social media as we
have it today or no social media no
Facebook no Twitter no YouTube no tumblr
no reddit are we societally society is
society better off without social media
at this point now in 2019 that's a good
question I'm thinking about the amount
if there was one off switch yeah yeah
yeah if they thinking about the anxiety
that it produces on an individual basis
and the FOMA in young people and this
desire to keep up with the Joneses and
front and flex and whatever I'm gonna go
ahead and say blogs are not social media
right I'm gonna be criminally and just
say I liked blogging was my best moment
for the a little bit if you create it
and host it yourself that's not social
media right but if a company is hosting
everyone's content yeah I'll call that
social media see it was so much more
sophisticated back there you'd write a
blog post you get backlinks which you
had the choice to list underneath your
blog post or not if you wanted to so
somebody could link to you you could or
anyone automatically place it you had
technorati you could see who was linking
to each other and what posts were rising
and falling just felt more intellectual
and considered it was also smaller
Internet this stuff is all new I mean I
think that's I'm feeling optimistic and
I think we're going to adapt to this
stuff just as humans right we're in this
early phase of all of this technology
really the internet broadly but
particularly social so you know maybe
our children will use this stuff in a
much better way than we do cuz we're
addicted and we do stupid things and
maybe we will figure out how to use it
better so when I'm feeling optimistic I
think it actually it's not social media
that's the problem it's awesome Allah
damn sometimes what we're seeing with
online bullying and you know to your
point
phlex saying which is having real-world
repercussions
and you know under service communities
I'm not at all certain that the the next
generation is using this better than us
I think that they're using it far worse
than it because they swim in it they
don't even see it they don't they don't
know where the boundaries are between
that in real life yeah I mean we all
grew up not on the internet the flip
side of that though is you have people
finding their communities it's the
transgendered kid / holder and so on
totally so that's that's why it's a
really challenging I mean you talk about
like the bullying and the sort of
elevated suicide rates and these sorts
of things like there's an open question
do those just stay where they're at or
is there oh no it's it's good it's gonna
increase I think I think the amount of
psychological stress that social media
puts on you we're adults who are
successful in this incredible industry
we know how technology works we get any
time and I think all white male yeah
unbelievable in fact this is the way
welcome to this week in white male
privilege I'm your host come around the
horn I mean you know you're absolutely
right right you don't you don't get to
be in a better position than then the
position that we get to occupy the thing
that is also heartbreaking to me is
people used to have a little bit more
independent thinking like they would
look at a situation and say okay let's
think about this Mueller report on the
bar thing let me get right though I felt
like it was when you're face to face
okay babes were never as good as we
remember them you know it just feels so
like it feels like everybody's reaction
is so tribal now and in order to get
outrage points like the name of the game
is to be outraged and how much outrage
points can I get like this kid who did
the fake attack in Chicago the Empire
anger is now exonerated you just
exonerated so now there's like a whole
nother outrage on the right and there
you know after everybody was outraged
that he was a gay man who was anti mega
magev went after him and then it was
fake and now he's released and it's just
I can't keep up with the rage so you're
not gonna flip the switch on social
media you're gonna keep it going
see where it goes I think that we I mean
it's obviously an interesting
intellectual exercise which in practice
you know
gonna keep using this stuff I think the
jury's still out I think we got to
figure out you know like I think about
my kids are a little bit young right
there they don't have phones they don't
have any of this stuff so I think about
well what am I gonna do when they get
there I think we're gonna do things like
say look the phone stays in the living
room and I'm gonna have to do that
myself which is tough I'll bring it to
the dinner table not have it around I
think we're gonna have to just figure
out coping mechanisms for these things
and I think actually you know the
technology will adapt as well I think
when you look at Facebook for example I
personally think that as they think
about long term sustainability this is
not good if you show up and everything
in your feed makes you angry like that's
not it's short term engaging but long
term I think that's not as sustainable
as something that might be less of that
or maybe a little bit more of this
whole-grain media so I think actually
the platforms are aligned with this long
term it's just hard to see this in the
short term metrics